when I tattoo people it gives them a
sense of identity and strength our
tattooing was a form of adornment Henner
our permanent makeup was our way to feel
beautiful and look beautiful my name is
Marjorie Taub own and I am helping
revitalize the ancient art of
traditional and unique tattooing all of
my tattoos have meaning that's deep to
me and to my family
and that's how all tattoos that I give
are I do two techniques one of them is
called hand poking or stick and poke and
that's where you have the needle and you
dip it in the ink and then you puncture
it into the skin I use our other ancient
technique of skin stitching with needle
and thread and that's where you have a
needle that's threaded and I use cotton
string and you dip the string in the ink
and then you pass the needle through the
skin in and out a little bit more
painful than the poking huh even though
we've had tattooing since time
immemorial thousands and thousands of
years revitalizing it and bringing it
back it's still new traditional early
tattooing the meanings vary from place
to place anyway women have always
received traditional chin tattoos
usually always meant when a woman became
of age the
thing is that it's important to the
person who's receiving them when the
missionaries came and colonization
started to happen you know tattooing
stopped it's been put to sleep for about
a hundred years me coming in as a young
Annabel woman
you know who am I to think that I could
do something that my ancestors did so
many years ago when I asked the elders
if it was okay to do this they said yes
you need to be strong and now it's
really kane' this revitalization effort
I can feel that strength and I can feel
that healing happening when I give a
tattoo I want to pass the knowledge as
best I can
I've dedicated my life to learning and
perpetuating our culture or the
betterment of our people and our youth
in the next generation
[Music]